>> Câu Di chúc: Giải pháp 3: Sử dụng hai hướng,
họ làm hai việc cùng một lúc, họ làm hai việc cùng một lúc.
Một trong JavaScript, một bên ngoài Java trên trình duyệt web.
Các chức năng mặt tiền vừa khởi động trình duyệt web nền hoạt động vừa
trong JavaScript, trả về đối tượng giữ chỗ được gọi là đối tượng hứa hẹn ngay lập tức,
điều đó sẽ được điền vào sau này.
Với giá trị từ hoạt động trình duyệt web nền, các tính năng của trình duyệt web hoạt động.
Được rồi, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Chúng tôi sẽ đi qua nó rất chính xác.
Dòng một, Michele biết làm điều này rất chậm.
Michele, chúng ta đang làm gì rất chậm trong lần đầu tiên của chúng ta,
Tôi cũng sẽ đi chậm thôi.
Rất chậm, Michelle,
trong dòng mã đầu tiên của chúng tôi, Michelle.
Chúng ta đang làm gì vậy? >> [ĐỦ]
>> Will Sentance: Đồng minh đầu tiên của chúng ta,
Michelle? >> Michelle: Chúng tôi đang sử dụng JavaScript để
tuyên bố [LAUGH] trong bộ nhớ- >> Di chúc: Rất tốt,
điều đó rất rõ ràng, tuyệt vời.
Một chức năng mà chúng tôi đang gọi là hiển thị.
Chúng tôi đang đặt tên cho nó, hãy cẩn thận, tôi cũng nói là đang gọi, nhưng
loại đó cho thấy chúng tôi đang chạy nó. >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi đang đặt tên cho màn hình,
bởi vì chúng tôi có thể bối rối khi nói rằng chúng tôi đang thực hiện nó, chúng tôi đang gọi nó.
Không, chúng tôi chỉ đặt tên cho nó, hiển thị.
Tôi biết bạn không ngụ ý điều đó, nhưng nói rõ ràng, màn hình hiển thị được lưu một cách xuất sắc.
Dòng tiếp theo, Brian, bên trái đầu tiên. >> Brian: Chúng tôi đang xóa một tên không đổi
dữ liệu trong tương lai. >> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc.
Được rồi, nó sẽ là gì theo nghĩa chung hơn?
Vâng, đó là gì, nó luôn luôn là kết quả của công việc của bên phải, vì vậy
đó là giá trị trả về của phía bên phải
thực hiện tìm nạp. >> Michelle: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Tốt, bạn có thể muốn
nói vậy, tôi xin lỗi nếu bạn đã.
Nhưng bây giờ, nó sẽ là gì ?. >> Brian: Không xác định.
>> Will Sentance: Chưa xác định, chúng tôi chưa
biết những gì để lưu trữ ở đó, chính xác.
Chúng tôi sẽ làm một số công việc ở phía bên phải.
Vì vậy, chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu chạy một hàm, tìm nạp.
Bây giờ ai nghĩ rằng tìm nạp hàm này tạo ra một bối cảnh thực thi theo cách
chúng ta đã quen?
Giơ tay.
Không, thay vào đó, cảm ơn James vì ​​đã tốt bụng cho chúng tôi một người.
Thay vào đó tìm nạp là gì?
Tìm nạp là một hàm mặt tiền.
Một mặt tiền cho một số công việc, thực sự tôi cho rằng nó có thể tạo ra một bối cảnh thực thi cho
điều này theo nghĩa mà chúng ta đã quen, nhưng nó vẫn là thứ nằm ngoài tầm kiểm soát của chúng ta.
Chúng tôi đã không viết tìm nạp, đây là một hàm che một loạt các JavaScript
hoạt động, chúng ta sẽ thấy điều đó trong giây lát và một loạt các trình duyệt web hoạt động.
Và nhân tiện, chúng tôi hy vọng với cách tìm nạp,
tìm nạp là tính năng mới này của trình duyệt và của JavaScript,
chúng tôi hy vọng nó sẽ trả lại cho chúng tôi dữ liệu từ Twitter và hy vọng một tweet.
Điều đó khá rõ ràng, đó là những gì chúng tôi hy vọng nó sẽ làm được.
Được rồi, hãy tìm nạp chức năng đầu tiên, hãy bắt đầu làm việc.
Chúng tôi sẽ cố gắng hoàn thiện hết mức có thể ở đây và
đây là nơi mà những suy nghĩ trở nên phức tạp.
Vì vậy, dữ liệu trong tương lai sẽ là giá trị trả về trong
JavaScript của tìm nạp cuộc gọi, tính năng trình duyệt web mới này
có nhãn JavaScript cho đối tượng địa lý.
Nhãn trong JavaScript được gọi là tìm nạp.
Ai biết được, tính năng của trình duyệt web là gì,
tìm nạp bắt đầu hay bắt đầu?
Vì nó không được gọi là tìm nạp.
Ai biết tính năng của trình duyệt web được gọi là gì?
>> Paul: xhr.
>> Will Sentance: Đó là xhr, tốt
Paul thực hiện.
Đó là XMLHttpRequest.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy điều đó có nghĩa là gì trong một giây nữa,
có vẻ như, chúng ta sẽ xem mỗi từ đó có nghĩa là gì.
Thành thật mà nói, tất cả chúng đều là viết tắt của những thứ, XML, HTTP, đều là những từ mới.
Yêu cầu rõ ràng là không.
Tuy nhiên, điều đó sẽ rất thú vị nếu có.
Có thể nó là.
Có thể request là một từ viết tắt. >> Will Sentance: Được rồi, tốt, vậy
điều này sẽ làm một cái gì đó trong JavaScript ngay lập tức.
Đặt hẹn giờ, nó không, đặt hẹn giờ chỉ xoay vòng tính năng trình duyệt web của chúng tôi.
Anh chàng nhỏ bé này ở đây, tìm nạp, mặc dù sẽ làm rất nhiều thứ trong JavaScript.
Nó sẽ ngay lập tức trả về một đối tượng,
ngay lập tức trả lại đối tượng với một tài sản
trên nó được gọi là giá trị, không được xác định.
Đây là nơi kết quả của dữ liệu này hoặc kết quả của công việc nền của tìm nạp
sẽ lưu trữ giá trị kết quả của chúng tôi từ công việc nền, khi nó quay trở lại.
Công việc nền đang nói với máy chủ của Twitter, mang lại một tweet.
Điều đó sẽ được điền vào đây.
Nó cũng có một thuộc tính trên đó, đó là một thuộc tính ẩn được gọi là sự hoàn thành.
Đó là một mảng, một danh sách, một mảng trống,
vào đó chúng tôi có thể gắn bất kỳ chức năng nào, nhưng
chúng tôi cũng muốn kích hoạt khi giá trị được cập nhật.
Thiết kế của vật thể đặc biệt này,
loại đối tượng mới trong JavaScript được gọi là đối tượng hứa hẹn.
Thiết kế của nó sao cho khi giá trị của nó được lấp đầy,
thì nó sẽ kích hoạt tất cả các chức năng trong mảng này trên mảng thực hiện.
Bây giờ, lý do chúng tôi muốn làm điều đó là sự trở lại này
đối tượng dot sẽ được lưu trữ trong dữ liệu trong tương lai.
Sunni, sự trở lại của đối tượng đó từ việc gọi tìm nạp sẽ được lưu trữ ở đâu?
>> Sunni: Tìm nạp dữ liệu.
Tôi xin lỗi, dữ liệu trong tương lai. >> Will Sentance: Dữ liệu tương lai, chính xác.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi có thể nghĩ rằng tôi có thể hiển thị futureData.value.
Nhưng vấn đề là tôi không biết khi nào giá trị đó sẽ được cập nhật.
Vì vậy, không có cách nào trong mã thông thường của tôi, tôi có thể viết futureData.value,
và sau đó đó sẽ là tweet trở lại của tôi.
Ví dụ: nói xin chào, rồi chạy hiển thị trên đó.
Nhưng đó là mục tiêu của tôi.
Tôi chỉ trả lại dữ liệu, vì vậy tôi có thể chạy chức năng trên đó.
Vì vậy, nếu tôi không biết khi nào dữ liệu đó sẽ quay trở lại,
Tôi không thể trong chuỗi mã đồng bộ được đặt hàng thông thường của mình,
hiển thị và chuyển vào futureData.value, vì tôi không biết giá trị là khi nào.
Tôi có thể cố gắng và tiếp tục viết như thế cho đến tận cùng đoạn mã của mình
display (futureData.value), sẽ là giá trị được đưa vào.
Nhưng khi nào tôi có thể chạy cái này?
Tôi không bao giờ biết ngày đó sẽ trở lại.
Vì vậy, nếu tôi muốn chạy chức năng trên dữ liệu của mình khi dữ liệu quay trở lại
công việc nền, nơi duy nhất tôi biết rằng giá trị chắc chắn được điền vào,
nơi duy nhất nó thực sự chắc chắn biết là vật thể này.
Vì vậy, chúng ta sẽ đính kèm các hàm đối tượng đó vào mảng này.
Bạn sẽ đẩy họ vào mảng đó.
Điều đó sẽ được tự động kích hoạt.
Khi giá trị được cập nhật.
Xem nó có cảm giác rất giống với những gì chúng tôi đã làm trước đây một cách trung thực.
Chúng tôi sẽ không thể làm điều này,
vì tôi vẫn không biết khi nào giá trị đó sẽ được cập nhật.
Vì vậy, nơi duy nhất tôi biết chắc chắn rằng giá trị đã được cập nhật,
lần duy nhất tôi biết chắc chắn là trên đối tượng này khi giá trị đó được điền vào và
sau đó tự động kích hoạt tất cả các chức năng này để chạy.
Và đó chính là thiết kế của đối tượng này, đối tượng hứa hẹn mới này trong JavaScript.
Khi giá trị được cập nhật, hãy kích hoạt tất cả các chức năng của tôi.
Nhân tiện, với giá trị, khi các hàm đó đầu vào.
Hiện tại chúng ta không có chức năng nào trong đó, nhưng chúng ta nên thêm một số chức năng vào.
Vì vậy, đó là đối tượng đi ra.
Nó được biết đến như một đối tượng hứa hẹn,
thông minh. >> Will Sentance: Vì vậy,
và điều đó được lưu trữ, như Sonia đã nói đúng, vào dữ liệu trong tương lai.
Nó có trong dữ liệu tương lai.
Nó có một thuộc tính giá trị, không được xác định.
Về cơ bản, nó có hai trình giữ chỗ, hai thứ đang chờ đợi.
Và nó có một thuộc tính ẩn được gọi là khi hoàn thành,
về cơ bản đó là một danh sách mà chúng tôi có thể đặt bất kỳ chức năng nào chúng tôi muốn để tự động kích hoạt
khi giá trị được cập nhật.
Và giá trị sẽ được cập nhật, khi tính năng trình duyệt web của chúng tôi lấy lại kết quả.
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy hy vọng cũng tìm nạp những gì, là hai hướng Nó cũng bắt đầu một nền
đó là tính năng của trình duyệt web, Paul? >> Paul: Yêu cầu HTTP XML.
>> Will Sentance: Yêu cầu HTTP XML,
thông minh.
Vì vậy, nó có hai hệ quả, một trong JavaScript.
Tôi thậm chí có thể viết điều đó thực sự.
Một trong JavaScript và một trong trình duyệt web,
một trong trình duyệt web, trình duyệt web.
Điều đó chính xác như Paul đã nói,
Yêu cầu HTTP XML, nghĩa là gì?
XML là dữ liệu trước đây mà chúng ta sẽ truy cập và lấy từ Internet,
khi chúng tôi xử lý nội dung trình duyệt web.
HTTP là giao thức, P là viết tắt của giao thức.
Điều đó có nghĩa là các quy tắc của trò chơi về cách chúng ta có thể đi và nhận được và
mang lại dữ liệu qua web và yêu cầu là yêu cầu,
đi và lấy dữ liệu, tốt.
Vì vậy, chúng ta hãy theo dõi hai điều, chúng ta hãy theo dõi nó ở đây.
Vì vậy, xhr là tính năng trình duyệt web mà chúng tôi đang sử dụng.
Đó là công việc, đó là một tính năng đặc biệt của trình duyệt,
tính năng quan trọng nhất của tất cả.
Khá rõ ràng, phải không?
Đó là một trong những nói với internet.
Đó là công việc.
Vì vậy, nó xoay một cái lên.
Thông tin nào nó cần biết,
Ben? >> Ben: URL.
>> Will Sentance: URL, tuyệt vời,
cảm ơn bạn, Ben.
URL, là Twitter.com, và cũng là đường dẫn / will.
Ngoài ra, điều khác nó cần biết là gì,
Ben? >> Will Sentance: Tìm hiểu mọi người về nó,
thực ra, có ai biết không, James? >> James: Phương pháp.
>> Will Sentance: Phương thức, được lấy,
nghĩa là nó sẽ nhận được một số dữ liệu, không phải gửi hoặc đăng như một tweet mới,
nó sẽ nhận lại các tweet.
Và tìm mọi người để có được, bạn nhé.
Nó đã hoàn thành chưa, Ben? >> Ben: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Chắc chắn là không, phải không,
1 phần nghìn giây, chúng ta đang ở 1 phần nghìn giây ở đây.
Nó chắc chắn hoàn thành một phần nghìn giây, phải không?
Nó sẽ, giả sử 200 mili giây, nó sẽ mất hoặc tương tự như vậy.
Khi hoàn thành, và đây là phần khó khăn, khi hoàn thành, Ben,
chúng ta muốn cái này làm gì?
Sau khi hoàn thành khi họ quay lại,
chúng ta muốn làm gì với dữ liệu đó? >> Ben: Chúng tôi muốn
gán dữ liệu phản hồi cho giá trị? >> Will Sentance: Anh ấy nói đúng?
Anh ấy đang ở đúng chỗ.
Trên đối tượng nào? >> Ben: Giá trị.
Đối tượng hứa hẹn. >> Will Sentance: Cái nào được gọi là?
>> Ben: Dữ liệu trong tương lai.
>> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc từ Ben.
Chúng tôi sẽ cập nhật futureData.value,
sẽ là bất kỳ dữ liệu nào chúng tôi nhận được từ tin nhắn của mình.
Thông điệp HTTP của chúng tôi tới Twitter.
Đây rồi, Twitter.
Đối với máy tính của họ.
Khi dữ liệu đó quay trở lại,
nó sẽ điền vào thuộc tính giá trị của đối tượng dữ liệu trong tương lai của chúng ta,
sau đó sẽ làm gì, Ben? >> Ben: Nó sẽ
kích hoạt các chức năng thực hiện? >> Will Sentance: Tất cả các chức năng trong
mảng thực hiện.
Chính xác. >> Will Sentance: Rất tốt.
Rất tốt.
Chúng ta có thể nói về mặc dù phân đoạn tìm nạp duy nhất đó đang hoạt động như thế nào không?
Đây là một chức năng mặt tiền hai mũi nhọn, không chỉ hoạt động trong trình duyệt web,
nó cũng thực hiện nhiều thứ bằng JavaScript.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi có sẵn trong JavaScript một khoảng trống nhỏ để hàm của chúng tôi,
trong đó giá trị trả về của chúng tôi, đối tượng phản hồi của chúng tôi.
Đó là phản hồi mà chúng tôi nhận được khi nói chuyện với Twitter dưới dạng một đối tượng,
sẽ được lưu trữ trong tài sản giá trị đó.
Ngay bây giờ nó vẫn chưa được xác định.
Ngay bây giờ chúng tôi thậm chí chưa nói những gì chúng tôi sẽ kích hoạt.
Nhưng chúng tôi sẽ làm trong giây lát.
Được rồi, tuyệt vời, công cụ tính năng của trình duyệt đã hoàn thành.
Đó là những gì tìm nạp đã thiết lập.
Nội dung JavaScript trả về dữ liệu trong tương lai ngay lập tức.
Và vì vậy chúng tôi có thể chuyển sang dòng tiếp theo trong chuỗi JavaScript của chúng tôi,
mà nói để làm gì, Ban phước?
Chúng tôi đã làm dữ liệu trong tương lai, với giá trị trả về là tìm nạp,
là đối tượng sa khoáng đối tượng.
Dòng tiếp theo của chúng ta là gì, Blessing? >> Blessing: Tính linh hoạt được đánh bài trên
dữ liệu trong tương lai. >> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc.
Phương thức tên yêu thích nhất của tôi trong JavaScript, .then.
Mọi thứ nó đang làm đều cho bạn biết,
rằng đó là công việc bằng cách nào đó, tôi thực sự không thích nó, nó khiến mọi người
nghĩ rằng bằng cách nào đó chúng ta sẽ quay lại dòng đó và sau đó hiển thị cuộc gọi.
Về cơ bản là không làm như vậy, sau đó làm cái gì?
Chà, Ben, chúng ta đặt các chức năng ở đâu
mà chúng tôi muốn được tự động kích hoạt, khi thuộc tính giá trị của dữ liệu trong tương lai
được cập nhật từ công việc nền? >> Ben: Vào dữ liệu tương lai
các đối tượng. >> Will Sentance: Xuất sắc.
Làm thế nào để chúng tôi đưa chúng vào đó?
Đó là công việc của chức năng được tích hợp sẵn này.
Tôi không nhớ liệu hàm máy chủ có ngụ ý loại mặt tiền này cho
trình duyệt web hoặc nếu không.
Đó là một loạt mã JavaScript được viết để làm điều này.
Nó được ghi vào, vì vậy đây là dữ liệu trong tương lai, đối tượng này ở đây.
Cùng một đối tượng chỉ cần chúng tôi chuyển nó ra và chúng tôi lưu trữ nó trong dữ liệu trong tương lai.
Nó có một thuộc tính được gọi là hoàn thành, là một mảng trống.
Tất cả những gì sau đó làm, nó nói bất cứ điều gì bạn chuyển cho tôi bất kỳ chức năng nào
định nghĩa, chúng tôi không chạy màn hình ở đây.
Biểu tượng nào cho tôi biết tôi đang chạy một hàm, Josh cái gì
biểu tượng đặc biệt nói rằng chạy một chức năng? >> Josh: Dấu ngoặc đơn.
>> Di chúc: Dấu ngoặc đơn,
Tôi không thấy dấu ngoặc ở đây, vì vậy chúng tôi không chạy màn hình.
Tất cả những gì chúng ta đang làm là định nghĩa toàn bộ hàm vào mảng đó.
Đó là tất cả những gì sau đó đang làm.
Sau đó, tôi sẽ thay thế tên bằng chức năng cửa hàng mà chúng tôi muốn tự động kích hoạt,
về giá trị có thể đang được cập nhật.
Nó không phải là một tên phương thức hấp dẫn, nhưng nó là một tên phương thức chính xác.
Into it going, nghĩa là chúng tôi đưa vào
mảng thực hiện, chức năng hiển thị.
Điều đó có nghĩa là bây giờ khi giá trị của chúng tôi được cập nhật, chúng tôi sẽ gọi hiển thị và
đầu vào của nó, đối số của nó.
Ngay bây giờ, dữ liệu của thông số, sẽ bị loại bỏ và
được thay thế bằng bất kỳ giá trị nào.
Và làm thế nào để chúng ta có được chức năng hiển thị đó trong danh sách các chức năng trên.
Làm thế nào để chúng tôi có được nó trong đó?
Sử dụng phương pháp then.
Bất cứ điều gì bạn vượt qua vì phương pháp của họ sẽ được đưa vào
đối tượng ở bên tay trái trên mảng thực hiện.
Chờ một chút, Josh.
Được rồi, nó gắn chức năng hiển thị với dữ liệu trong tương lai.
Nó hoàn toàn không phải nói, chạy hiển thị ngay bây giờ.
Cảm giác rất nhiều, ý tôi là bạn nhìn vào cái này và
rất tốt, dữ liệu trong tương lai sẽ quay trở lại và sau đó chúng ta cần chạy hiển thị.
Vâng, về lý thuyết, theo nghĩa ẩn dụ rộng hơn là có.
Nhưng không, những gì chúng tôi thực sự đang làm là chúng tôi tham gia vào tương lai
một đối tượng hứa hẹn có thuộc tính giá trị chưa được điền vào.
Khi nó được điền vào, chúng tôi sẽ kích hoạt tất cả các chức năng này.
Làm thế nào để chúng ta có được các chức năng trong đó?
Sử dụng phương thức then trên đối tượng futureData.
Được rồi, có nghĩa là bây giờ chúng ta có thể tiếp tục với mã đồng bộ của mình và
ở mức 2 mili giây, những gì chúng tôi đã làm cho bạn hôm nay. sau đó, dòng nào của
chúng ta đạt được mã ở 2 mili giây, Bryan? >> Brian: Console.log.
>> Will Sentance: Console.log, vâng.
>> Brian: Tôi trước.
>> Will Sentance: Console.log cho tôi trước,
thông minh.
Console.log cho tôi trước.
Đó là 2 mili giây.
Brian, chúng ta đã đạt được rất nhiều
mục tiêu rất quan trọng là có thể thiết lập các nhiệm vụ mất nhiều thời gian, nhưng
tiếp tục mã JavaScript thông thường của chúng tôi? >> Brian: Vâng.
>> Will Sentance: Theo cách không chặn.
Tuyệt vời, chúng tôi có.
Bạn đang ở đúng chỗ.
Sau 2 mili giây, chúng tôi tiếp tục với mã của mình.
Được rồi, và bây giờ trong JavaScript, chúng ta đã khá rõ ràng.
Thành thật mà nói, chúng tôi khá rõ ràng ngay bây giờ.
Được rồi, nhưng trong tính năng trình duyệt web nền của chúng tôi, một thế giới nội dung đang diễn ra.
Máy chủ của Twitter đang gửi lại cho chúng tôi phản hồi có thể là 201 mili giây,
thứ gì đó tương tự, cộng với 200 mili giây,
>> Will Sentance: Điều đó đến, phản hồi của chúng tôi
đó là câu trả lời đơn giản nhất của tôi.
Bây giờ rõ ràng, nó quay trở lại, thực sự rõ ràng, khi nó đến
trở lại dưới dạng một đối tượng khi chúng ta phải đi vào và tìm giá trị thực trong phần thân.
Nhưng chúng tôi sẽ đơn giản hóa nó và nói rằng nó sẽ trở lại như một chuỗi ký tự đẹp, hi.
Vì vậy, Rick tại thời điểm đó,
nếu chúng tôi vừa lấy lại chủ đề phản hồi thì có nhiệm vụ xhr nền của chúng tôi,
yêu cầu dữ liệu, chúng tôi đã lấy lại dữ liệu.
Nó đã hoàn thành chưa?
>> Rick: Vâng. >> Will Sentance: Nó có
hoàn thành, tại chỗ.
Nó đã hoàn thành và như vậy, Ben,
chúng ta sẽ kích hoạt điều gì xảy ra? >> Rick: Chúng tôi sẽ chỉ định
chuỗi đó thành futureData.value. >> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
giao tiếp rất tốt, vâng, chính xác.
Nghĩa là. >> Will Sentance: Chúng ta sẽ làm gì
kích hoạt chạy?
Chúc phúc, hãy đơn giản nhất có thể ở đây, chúng ta sẽ kích hoạt những gì
điểm này? >> Ban phước: Được rồi,
bây giờ giá trị đã quay trở lại, chúng tôi sẽ kích hoạt chức năng hiển thị.
>> Di chúc: Chính xác,
bây giờ chúng tôi sẽ giữ lại, bây giờ chúng tôi chỉ nói rằng chúng tôi sẽ kích hoạt nó.
Chúng tôi quay lại với tốc độ khoảng 201 mili giây.
Chúng tôi sẽ kích hoạt nó chạy ở 200 mili giây.
Chúng tôi sẽ khám phá,
chúng tôi có thực sự nghĩ rằng JavaScript sẽ cho phép chức năng đó hoạt động trở lại không?
Hay sẽ có một số bước trung gian?
Có thể, nhưng bây giờ chúng ta chỉ cần nói, chúng tôi kích hoạt màn hình đang chạy, với hi, phải không?
Chúng tôi nhìn vào màn hình hiển thị chức năng mà chúng tôi đang kích hoạt.
Chúng tôi thấy thông số của nó là dữ liệu.
Chúng ta gọi nó.
Dữ liệu tham số được thay thế bằng giá trị,
Victor? >> Victor: Xin chào.
>> Will Sentance: Xin chào, xuất sắc.
Tuyệt vời, và do đó trong bộ nhớ của chúng tôi, chúng tôi có dữ liệu tham số với một giá trị, xin chào.
Và sẽ truy cập console.log,
ở 201 mili giây. >> Will Sentance: Giá trị của chúng tôi.
>> Will Sentance: Xin chào, đây là mọi người,
trời ơi. >> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi đã đạt được ba
mục tiêu, một, tập hợp các tác vụ cần nhiều thời gian trong trình duyệt web, hai tiếp tục
chạy qua mã JavaScript, nó đánh tôi đầu tiên, không vấn đề gì, không bị chặn.
Thứ ba, khi dữ liệu đó quay trở lại từ tác vụ nền,
không nó sẽ hiển thị ở đâu và
thì chức năng tự động kích hoạt tại thời điểm đó với đầu vào của dữ liệu đó.
Tôi sẽ cho bạn biết điều này.
Nhân tiện, nó trông rất giống với mô hình trước đó.
Chúng ta vừa có một bước trung gian.
Bây giờ chúng tôi chỉ cập nhật một giá trị trong JavaScript để tự động kích hoạt hàm.
Trước đây, nếu bạn nhớ, với thời gian chờ đã đặt,
chúng tôi chuyển một hàm trong đó sẽ được tự động kích hoạt với giá trị.
Bây giờ chúng ta chuyển một tham chiếu đến một vị trí trong bộ nhớ JavaScript,
một thuộc tính giá trị được điền vào khi hoàn thành.
Và đó là những gì kích hoạt hàm để gọi.
Tôi không biết.
Cải thiện khả năng đọc có thể.